there's been some reporting that the nfl
and the nfl players association are at
odds
over whether or not players who test
positive for the virus will be
on injured reserve or the non-football
illness list now the non-football
illness list if you put a player on that
during the season they're done for the
year and
they
potentially if the team chooses not to
pay them don't get another penny as of
last night espn was reporting that's
still a sticking point i had other
people saying it's not a sticking point
we have a deal on what it's going to be
my understanding
and this is all subject to league
approval
but the deal between the league and the
union will allow players to be placed on
a short-term covet 19 ir list
and then they come off of that list and
go back to the roster
and while they are on that list
they will be replaced on the roster by
someone else the goal is to ensure that
you have as many healthy bodies as
possible you have maximum flexibility
now the way it was explained to me
three weeks on the covet 19 list then
you can return to practice and once you
get to the point where you can return to
practice you've got a three week window
to get back to the active roster at the
end of that three weeks it's either
active roster injured reserve or injury
settlement and the player leaves the
team
i've heard some concerns from the
player's perspective about why do you
have to be shut down for three weeks on
the front end what if you're
asymptomatic what if within five days
you can generate two negative tests why
should you be kept off of the roster for
three whole weeks simply because you
tested positive and you have no symptoms
so there may be some lingering push and
pull on the contours of the covet 19 ir
list in fact if you're the team why do
you want to have your guys
set aside for a minimum of three weeks
that doesn't make any sense if there is
a way they can get back sooner than that
but that's where it currently stands
we'll see how that plays out but the
teams are not going to do anything to
have rules that are so rigid that the
players get screwed because it's not
their fault if they test positive and
you're never going to be able to prove
that it didn't happen
at work so the players get paid whatever
the final rules are and the final rules
will encourage the ability for teams to
have as many players available
as possible you want to be able to
withstand an outbreak you want to be
able to plug in other players and you
don't want a situation where
your players who have tested positive
are still taking up roster spots that
could be devoted to players who are
negative for the virus and who could
come in even if they're only there for a
couple of weeks and i think we'll also
see some flexibility on the moves that
are made on the practice squad already
for this year you can move guys two of
them up and down without passing them
through waivers i suspect that maybe
more guys from the practice squad will
be eligible to go up to the active
roster and then back down in the event
of a covet 19 positive designation
without passing through waivers and
giving another team a chance to pounce
on a guy who goes from the active roster
back to the practice squad so look they
get this all figured out
if they want training camp to open
a lot of people are saying it really
doesn't make sense to open training camp
right now especially in the cities that
are in the midst of the greatest rate of
increased cases like houston like dallas
like miami like l.a
whatever the final decision
we are at the point where decisions need
to be made and i'd say by this time
tomorrow when we do friday's pftpm we
should be at a point where we have a
pretty good idea of what what the rules
are
and what the rules aren't so teams
either will or won't be proceeding with
training camp and i will not be
surprised if the end result is they
decide to get rid of the preseason and
bump everything back a couple of weeks
and give everyone a chance to to really
prepare for what's to come because once
they're there they're there you don't
want to start it up and then shut it
down you want to wait until the point
where you're confident you can get it
roll and it's going to work right
it's and if you rush and this is the
sentiment that jj watt shared with us
last week if you rush
when you shouldn't
you may have the season collapse
when it otherwise
we'll see how it all
plays out we're hoping for football
season again addressing the various
hurdles the nfl faces does not in any
way mean we are rooting against it why
in the hell and almost said a word
stronger than hell would we root against
it we want football we can't wait for
football and hopefully football will
find a way to coexist with a pandemic
that has gotten worse instead of better
because there are too many stupid
selfish people out there who have failed
to take this seriously who have failed
to do what they need to do and those are
the people as i said yesterday who are
complaining the most if there's no
football let's all resolve to do what we
need to do let's wear a mask let's stay
home when we need to let's find a way to
do the things that need to be done in
the safest way possible and let's hope
that it's not too late to salvage
football season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports